the winter storm has lashed Spain
bringing whiteout snow conditions and
winds of more than 140 kilometres an
hour
Gloria triggered weather alerts across
the country with some saying it could be
the worst ocean storm here the century
sea waters been pouring into the embro
Delta one of Spain's most important
wetlands flooding thousands of hectares
of rice crops the local mayor said he'd
never seen anything like it
locals in Girona looked on nervously as
the anja River rose almost breaking its
banks yesterday city officials told us
that water could possibly enter our shop
so we put this yet to try to prevent
water getting in because it would be a
major disaster at one point two hundred
thousand people were without power and
tens of thousands of students out of
school as roads remained impassable
in Mariah snow plows were brought in and
drivers dug into the drifts to find
their cars we had to spend a couple of
days here we were supposed to leave
yesterday but we couldn't because
everything was covered in even more snow
than it is now some were forced to use
more unconventional methods to forge a
path the only thing I could think about
was this tray from the kitchen because
we are waiting for shovels we decided we
better use whatever we had at home and
improvise a little bit
this isn't snow even though it looks
like it it's sea foam flooding the
streets of the small town of tossa de
mar about a hundred kilometres up the
coast from Barcelona
the storms gale force winds smashed into
several seafront towns damaging shops
and restaurants some waves were a
record-breaking 13.5 meters high as they
slammed into the shore
Barcelona's famous beaches didn't escape
the storm but they still pulled the
crowds and while several people thought
the weather was worth documenting
scientists expect scenes like this to
become more common along this coast
because of climate change
Alexey Brian al-jazeera